Can I ask you about love? Oh, sure.
Uh, I'm feeling it, you know, like we're an hour or two here. Lacks. Yeah.
You feel you're good. We're good. We're good. We got a bromance going here.
I feel it too. It's Eric Weinstein level, but I feel like it's close.
Yeah. I'm feeling the love. But you, we talked about the
music to my ears,
your whole rant on the Olympic nature of a startup.
Is there a role,
like what role does love family friendship play in
that brutal pursuit of excellence that
is building a startup, building a company or building any,
creating anything new in this world?
Such a great question. Um, and, and totally unprepared for it, uh,
because I knew nobody would ever ask me about that. So I think it's why you've,
you've, you've got quite a following, uh, uh,
on your podcast is that you're able to ask these questions and, um,
I can tell one story because, uh, you know, I don't talk about,
I try not to talk about relationship with you on that often, because you know,
he's so famous now. I mean, when we met,
I used to go out to parties with him and people like, Oh my God,
you're Jason Cox. I was like, yeah. And like, who's your friend. I'm like,
that's my friend, Eli and he's. And they'd be like,
why did he do doing rocket ships? But he's told this story publicly,
but I can tell it. And it would never talk about having that.
He hasn't already talked about publicly, especially since he saw high-profile,
but it was pretty funny moment. Um, he, there,
there was a moment in time when Tesla almost went out of business and you've
probably heard this story, uh, many times,
but it was during the financial crisis and, uh,
they were running out of money and I said, uh, uh,
you know, let's go get a steak. And we're in LA.
And we drove to boa and I had my orange Tesla Roadster and he had his P one or P
two, like the red one that I think is in space now. Um,
and we drove to the valet and we had a steak together and we're sitting there
and I said, you know, I read the story in Gawker or whatever, you know,
and New York times here, you only got like five weeks of money left in Tesla.
He goes, it's not true. I was like, Oh, thank God. And he goes,
we have two weeks.
I got caught.
I was like, well, what's going on with the rocket ship company? You know, like,
you know, I know you did the one last month and you don't,
you have one coming up and he's like, yeah, we got the third one coming up.
I was like, well, how's that going as well with blow that one up.
But there was no more space X. I was like,
so two weeks of money left in Tesla and space X,
you blew up the first two rockets. You blow up the third space. X's over.
He's like, yeah. I was like, I can loan you a couple million dollars.
I don't have like a ton. Um, he's like, it's okay.
Our friend has loaned me some money and has been super
public about this. I would never tell the story in, listen, he hadn't been in,
but he was talking to me. He never said who it was,
but somebody had loaned him money to keep them afloat. He was,
he was functionally bankrupt. I mean, he had the equity in the companies,
but the equity was quickly becoming worth zero and the financial crisis.
And he is figuring out if he's going to go on vacation for Christmas or not.
And he's on the phone trying to, you know, um, you know, save the,
save both companies. And I said, certainly there must be some good news.
And he takes that as Blackberry to date this conversation, there are no iPhones,
Taylor's Blackberry. And he starts swiping and he says, don't tell anybody,
this is what I'm building. And he shows me the model S
and nobody knew that it was working on the model.
S we knew he was doing the ma the Roadster,
and he was trying to save the company. And I looked at it and I was like,
that's gorgeous. Um, it was the clay models.
So it was a full-size clay model.
So there's human beings standing around a clay version of this tiny little
Blackberry picture I'm scrolling through on the, remember that little, uh,
pad or the ball on flat ground scrolling through it. I'm like, this is great.
And I just said to him, I was like, what's the range going to be? He says, well,
I think we get 250 miles. I was like 250 miles. It's like, yeah,
I think it'd be the safest car ever. I said, what is it going to cost? He says,
I think this could cost eventually 50, $60,000. I said,
Elon, if you make that car, you'll change. The world you have to,
this company must survive because the Roadsters for like
2000 people in United States, this car is for every person, the United States,
every single person that I say it's needs will want this car. If it's $50,000,
maybe some of the people who you have 20 or $30,000, won't be able to afford it,
but the law wanted it's gorgeous. And he said, you really think so? I was like,
yeah. So I got home and I talked to my wife, Jade, and I said,
you have the checkbook. She does all the finances and stuff like that.
Pays the bills and whatever. And I said, um, yeah,
don't tell anybody he wants making this gray car.
And I wrote two checks for $50,000.
And I just took out his paper and I wrote E comma, uh,
love, love the new car. I'll take two. I signed it.
I kissed the two 50,000 checks, put them in the envelope.
And I FedEx it to him for Monday delivery.
And I said to Jade that a hundred thousand dollars is going to be gone in
48 hours because it will pay for one or two days of payroll on Tesla.
So we just added like, instead of two weeks in a row, he's got 12 days. Yeah.
And, uh, the checks don't care.
But then I read a story that he's closed the money.
He saved the company and like the next week or two,
and a couple of months later, uh, the checks get cashed and I'm like,
okay, three years later, I get an email.
Your reservation number from Tesla. Yeah.
Your reservation number is zero zero zero zero zero zero zero one.
And then five seconds later, your reservation number is zero zero zero, zero 73.
And I forward the number one Yolanda. I said, uh, you know,
I can't take number one, signature, number one, I can't take that. That's yours.
And he's like, well, I got five of them.
And besides you're the first person that ordered it.
And I was the first person who had seen it.
I know it was a very peaceful moment.
It was an incredible moment for both of us. And we talk about it sometimes, uh,
you know, those moments in time. And when you,
to your point about love and Nila darkest moment,
but one of the darkest moments in his life, probably that I can tell you,
it was the darkest period of his life, for sure. Um,
and he's been very public about how dark that was. And I think, you know,
this is why I have great sympathy for the entrepreneurs of the world,
like the suffering and the pain.
And when he talks about the suffering and the pain that all of these founders
have felt,
and then we were throwing rocks at them and we're criticizing them as they try
to change the world and save humanity. And in Tesla's case, I mean,
they weren't, you know, they, they weren't like delivering pizza. I mean,
they were trying to get us off of fossil fuels.
Like this was a big heady mission to literally save the environment,
the planet humanity, and the way they shorted that stock. And they attacked him.
It was always perplexing to me.
Why any human being who is standing on God's green
earth would want to throw rocks at the guy who is trying to
STEM the dam of global warming Medis about to engulf all of us,
how dare they throw rocks at that guy?
There's so many people you throw rocks at.
There's somebody who's making the Juul vaporizer throw rocks at that scumbag,
no offense, but like whoever's making the Juul things and, you know,
selling pina colada flavor to 12 year olds like throw rocks at them.
Somebody is doing something, you know, at porridge, but not E I mean, and, uh,
yeah, anyway, that, that car is, you know,
up the road here sitting under a cover with 20,000 miles on it in my garage.
And then the roads there, number 16 is in the garage next to it.
And every day I walked by the two of them and I got a warm feeling in my heart.
Cause I know he did it against all odds against all odds.
He pulled it off. Uh, and it was that moment,
that month in that too, that it was Jan. It was probably December, January,
December of 2008. I think it was just 12 years ago.
When you think about 13 years ago, it was dark. I mean,
it was dark and they almost had the same thing happen. Uh, you know,
when the model three production in June of two years, three years ago.
And I remember him just trying to get the model three out the door and the
company almost crashed then.